[Music]
remembering sheldon adelson the
billionaire mogul who built a casino
empire spanning from las vegas to china
passes away at the age of 87. good
afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us at 4 o'clock i'm kirsten
joyce
and i'm christian casadis just last week
adelson announced he would be stepping
back from leading las vegas sands
to undergo more treatment in his long
battle against non-hopkins lymphoma
he passed away yesterday in california
from complications related to the
treatment
according to a statement from the las
vegas sands corporation joe muller jones
joins us live from the venetian and
palazzo with a look at how adelson made
an impact here in las vegas
adelson is not only highly known in las
vegas for his property and convention
center but also internationally with
hotels in singapore and macau
we're here on the las vegas strip
outside the palazzo you can see this
billboard here is paying tribute to him
many are remembering the influence he
had on and
off the strip billionaire las vegas
casino mogul sheldon adelson passed away
monday
while born in boston in 1933 a good
portion of his life was las vegas
in the late 80s he purchased the sands
hotel and casino which eventually was
replaced by the venetian
then he built the palazzo las vegas
sands also expanded with several resorts
in asia
our city and our state
is such such a better place
because of sheldon adelson steve hill
ceo of the las vegas convention and
visitors authority recognized adelson's
impact
he had a tremendous influence on what we
do
on the meetings in convention industry
adelson also helped bring the state's
first nfl team to las vegas it's
important to point out
that mr allison was was really the
driving force behind the legion stadium
the billionaire was a veteran and a
major financial contributor to the
republican party and president trump
adelson and his wife miriam were
well-known philanthropists donating
millions to anti-drug and jewish
organizations
there are many many things that mr
adelson and dr aderson
have been involved in their philanthropy
journey in
medical breakthrough in the connection
between the jewish people
all around the continuity of the jewish
people
all around the world
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the monitor outside the
palazzo according to las vegas sands
adelson will be buried in israel and
another service
is expected to happen here in las vegas
we are still waiting to get more
information
on that reporting live on the las vegas
strip this evening joe mullen 8 news now